uh hello everyone um welcome to another
woven language design review part of our
incremental language design
series and we have a few topics here
first
tree visuals
uh this is presumably still for 13.1 is
that correct
um
okay
so
those look nice to me those ones look
nice now what's this one
that one
tree element
none
as opposed to an unlabeled tree
right
unlabeled tree sets a bunch of other
options
so let me just understand
if i
were to try
okay why did that do what it did because
that was just wrong
i was just wrong this pr was just merged
yesterday
no i mean multiple things are wrong
there the aspect ratio is wrong
and the
i mean i don't have to do this nonsense
do i
do i have to do that nonsense because i
shouldn't have to do that nonsense
that's not okay
it will look exactly like above with the
green circles and by the way why didn't
that work
unlabeled trees should take the same
options as tree takes
shouldn't it
yes and that's fixed
right now okay
right
so i basically can't see this right now
no you ask about aspect ratio though
what's determining that
it's
the automatic aspect ratio from graph
can somebody explain how that's
determined
because i'm not sure the heuristic is
right for trees
i don't know i i don't think there is i
mean right we had charles last time to
mention it and he's like
well i'd have to look into it so
well sufficiently complicated that
we
i don't think anybody can immediately
answer the question okay
let's try to get an answer to this i
mean in other words oh let's figure out
what we think it should be
i mean what what heuristics can we
imagine for these aspect ratios
i mean in in a sense
what we're trying to do
okay what are we trying to achieve we're
trying to achieve some density of
nodes
what the heck are we trying to achieve
maybe it's worth considering the cases
where it's unintelligible and then just
trying to avoid those
yeah well so for example let's do a tree
that just has a zillion nodes coming out
what would be the how would i generate
one of those
a one level tree i'll do an s3 and
change the three to like
seven
that's tree what do i what do i say that
input below
oh i see
no i didn't mean that i mean a single
node
tree of range you just want a single
node with a ton of children yes dude
like tree of range of a thousand
oh i see delights like that
that is not a good illusion that that
that illusion symbol is like from
version one
yep uh we have a talk about this we
created a design ticket last time
uh for this to improve that okay
how do i how do i get this to try and
show the thing i mean i think that's a
little bit
you know not tall enough probably
so if i say if i give an aspect ratio
here
oh oops in the tree
in the tree arboreal aspect ratio
that's not very good either
so what do we think where
i kind of think that looks pretty decent
whereas
what do other people think i think that
looks better than this
in fact i think one criterion is
by the time the lines are crossing over
like that it's bad news
so maybe try an example where well they
are crossing over a little bit even in
the one quarter
at least that's how it looks to me over
zoom well one the one okay now they're
not
no they're not but that the original
size oh okay there yes okay it did but
somehow that looks significantly better
that aspect ratio of quarter crystal
try the harder case just do nest tree of
range of a hundred comma one comma three
i'm not sure if that'll be too big
but um one comma 100 comma range
range of 100
ampersand comma one comma three
i'm not again i'm not sure that's too
big maybe do 25 instead of range of 100.
[Music]
yeah try something smaller
well that's absolutely hopeless
well i'm just trying to make something
that's a bit deeper but also has these
very high degree things that i'm
visualization max children if you want
to control the illusion
no i i don't care about controlling but
actually in that case why did it
that's probably just a bug that it
showed up as like almost totally flat
right this is wrong i mean the the
okay so let's does nest tree take an
aspect ratio option or not
okay so this is clearly the wrong
heuristic here
right the one quarter is actually
looking fairly decent on this one as
well
so why does one quarter look decent
what is the i mean is it okay here's a
question because these are relatively
shallow trees right i mean okay i've got
a criterion for you guys the angle
at a tree node
shouldn't be more than such and such
right we'll try to try the really tall
tree because that's the converse thing
so let's just see what that looks like
so there's no nest tree of of list one
or something like that comma one comma
ten or maybe more than ten a hundred
well that's for that case it handles
fine
what if you do like one two
right
i don't know what's this okay me too
that's what an aspect of a quarter
oh right
yeah well that's a fail
yeah does it seem like there's some
problems with very wide graphs i mean if
nothing else it seems like there should
be a maybe there should even be a
minimum
maximum width yeah it seems like they
can be arbitrarily tall
but they they probably shouldn't be
arbitrarily wide
i don't know
right see the point is that for for
ordinary graphs
if i do a path graph
okay
charles wants it to look like that and
he's right
okay but for trees you never want it to
look like that
for trees there should be a minimum
aspect ratio i climb
except vertically
they are arbitrarily narrow but not
arbitrarily wide
because as we saw with the case we did
nest tree just list one
you know that just looks like a vertical
path graph yeah i know but that that's a
very large aspect ratio
yeah
it's founded on one side but not the
other that's correct yes so i'm claiming
it never should get smaller than a
quarter
see what i'm saying
and you understand what i'm saying
because this is clearly wrong
right not sure a quarter a quarter might
be even two
might maybe maybe
maybe it can be a little wider than a
quarter i don't know
maybe we need some counter maybe there
are some counter examples
but but i think the first cut a quarter
should be the minimum
ian are you here with us yeah
i mean do you disagree
but the word minimum makes me nervous
like exactly how are we going to compute
the aspect ratio in other cases
like i could
i know what i'm saying
if nothing else you can just use
whatever the automatic graph one is and
then change it if it's less than a
quarter i mean that would be a
dumb way to do it
that's what i would that's what i'm
saying the first step would be that in
order to avoid this case
right because as i say what charles has
done which makes perfect sense given
that he's got pathographs
right but you cannot have a graph that
looks like this
but your thing always has to have a
height
unless you're rotating your tree
right i mean right i am we have to be
careful about that yep we have to be
careful about that
right
but so
okay so that my my next claimed
criterion is this angle criteria what do
you think of the angle criteria
seems
reasonable
okay so
can you compute that angle easily
can you compute look what you're going
to have let's take one of these trees
okay here
all right so
who can think through the code quickly
to compute the angle distribution in
this tree
so presumably i can get the coordinates
of every of every node
and what i'm doing is for every node
what are the actual coordinates of its
children and then i take the some kind
of arctan or something to get that angle
do you understand what i'm saying
so we don't have a way to extract like
annotation values from trees currently
you could convert this to a graph
and pull the coordinates out of that
okay
okay
so now what do we recommend here are you
trying to get a span of angles like are
you trying to get i'm trying to get a
history this left one is like this no no
but but by angles do you mean the
absolute angle like this edge is almost
horizontal or do you mean the relative
angle as in this edge is pointing this
way and this other edge at the same
vertex is pointing the other way you
know i have to say my angle criterion i
think is blown up by this picture
because this picture these things are
very splayed out almost 180 degrees but
it looks right
okay what do we think about the aspect
ratio of this tree
it seems to look pretty good to me
so i mean if we say
um let's just take this and let's just
for the hell of it i mean as i said i
think it's a winner right now
um
really what did that just do
okay compare and contrast
well actually i kind of like the aspect
ratio one
yeah
it's a deep tree
and that you know
looks like some kind of hanging gardens
type
thingy there
whereas this
i kind of do prefer this one so okay so
let's understand how we would how we
would learn
you know which of these is better
i mean the other thing we could do
is look at some published trees
and see what people have they probably
did a bad job never mind that idea
so i'm curious if we take one of really
bad examples and give it the options to
display left to right do we get
something reasonable looking or do we
get a different fail
one of these for example yep
okay
how do we say to display it tree layout
arrow left
you get a different fail
yeah
right now that's the same fail you know
what i mean i suppose yes it's it's the
same fail it's just
yes rotate at 90 degrees but it's a bit
disappointing we didn't do better
yeah so i mean in this case if i say
aspect ratio
the aspect ratio is pre it's post
rotation so i want to say aspect ratio 4
here is that correct
i believe so
okay
much more reasonable
but so now if i went down to two for
example
yeah i mean that's getting progressively
better probably but we never want to get
a situation where i claim it looks
really bad
if you have too small an angle
okay so here's my criterion here
so let's try one here
yeah i'm i don't know that's sort of
okay in this particular case okay so i'm
going to make a claim
that
if you even if you take a thing like
this well let's take tree
range of five for example okay so now
let's let's go ahead and um
okay okay so i think there's an
intermediate value that's good because
you make it too tall i mean even too
tall it's no good one
that that looks pretty flat it's also no
good right so so what we're seeing here
is for this case values between let's
say
i think that's about as low as you go
point two
to about i'm not sure it's as low as you
go because that's that's i mean
you saw that example above where it had
just those two children and it was super
super wide
yeah okay but no i understand but oh
but i mean i'm saying for this
particular tree
it's between like point two and point
five i claim
i mean it's it's sort of looking okay
there but if we make it pointier than
that it looks wrong
okay so what is the criterion so i think
the criterion is
what what causes this to look wrong
i think that one honestly i mean there's
there's the problem of interpretability
and there's a problem of ugliness this
one is just ugly
yeah i agree but why
i mean partly i think it's because the
the distance between the the children
the parent is so far like you can't
really have them the same like uh
yes okay
can we just see if jeremy happens to be
available maybe he would have an
immediate
reaction to this
somebody do that please yeah i can check
on that we also have billy here right
now oh billy is here okay well does
billy have an opinion about this
yeah i agree the uh parent seems a
little bit too far away
can you express
you know
a reasoned reason for why that doesn't
look right
in other words between this which
clearly doesn't look right
that's too flat
yeah but but so
you know
design wise
talk about what
you know
it's like what makes one of these look
right versus looking wrong
it's kind of almost the physicality of
the thing if you were making i don't
know
go ahead yeah yeah and it's like you
it's almost like you kind of want to be
able to control the bottom layer too so
if it goes up a little then they kind of
come in
because right now they're sort of
stationary so you don't get
what do you mean i mean
this is the look the control we have
right now is pure aspect ratio here this
is so between for five members for five
outputs we are okay so let's record this
five
you know a five-membered tree
think we can go between point two aspect
ratio between point two and point five
we said right is that right
yep
two two point five okay so now i think
it'll be the same if you have a
5
000
member tree
okay let's check check that hypothesis
okay
okay we're not going to do 5 000 but
let's do 30 or something here
okay oh gosh can i reset this to
actually show 30
yeah so do trees backtick
visualization match max children
the option as an option
visualization max children
how are we
how are we actually um presenting that
to users
it's undocumented i understand that what
are we going to do to make it not
undocumented because it seems like a
useful thing to have
when we have that illusion mechanism we
need a way to get around the illusion
mechanism
right
so what will be an analogous option
somewhere else
and then we need to name it here and put
it in
max items yeah
yeah it is it's like max items isn't it
um
but max is max items also governs does
not just govern display
or does it
are the cases where it just governs
display
yeah
data set for example
right it's not how big your page is but
it's not doesn't affect
anything about the data itself
i feel like max items
would be unclear because it's per
yeah i mean i i don't think it's the
right name for this for this usage but
okay so what in you've said
do you use the term children
yes
in what in what function
tree children
okay so this is really like max
displayed tree children
is that right
at each node right
so
yeah so it's an option oh i see max
displayed children what what are you
saying christopher you had a
no i was just cutting the tree children
because the tree seems unnecessary
i would i think that's a reasonable
option anybody got a different
suggestion
and that would be an option an option in
every tree in every tree element
right yeah so right now this globally
controls all nodes i guess it could be
made
like per node
well you should do the same jazz that
you're doing with your all arrow blah
blah blah blah i think
yep
um
okay so
here
christopher seems to be right that this
is no more this doesn't help oops
i think i have the impression that i
like seeing as many possible lines being
45 degrees
yes actually stove on a live stream says
looks like if you think of that tree as
a triangle then the top angle should be
between 60 and 120
they say well that was the thing you
were saying earlier but then with that
that that bigger one we saw we saw that
there were some edges that were like
almost 180.
yeah i know so let's look at that one
look i think
in some sense
no i'm that's a nonsense thing i was
going to say in some sense you want the
mass
if i think about this as a mass
distribution
okay let's let's talk about a different
thing let's talk about this as a um
uh what on my earth am i saying as a as
a mobile you know one of those things
you hang up that kind of
wobbles around you know what i'm saying
yep
the
um
what
i mean again i may be completely crazy
here if that's a but this looks a bit
like one of those
and if i then say um
uh
you know maybe this is just a nuts thing
to do but let's let's try um
uh
that's also because that's a relatively
balanced tree which doesn't have to be
yes that's true that's true
um
and i have a bad feeling that these are
uh these things that look very much like
that tree
um
okay this was an unhelpful
direction i think
although
it is sort of interesting that that many
of these
i think the key takeaway is we need
umbrella-shaped vertices
well
what i mean there is some elegance to
these things they have a certain of
course that's just because they're
basically balanced
never mind okay so let's take this
example
let's look at this example and let's see
what it would take to make it look bad
okay
so that aspect ratio i i think you're
definitely right that this aspect ratio
is better than the suspect ratio
why
okay let's make a manipulate out of that
um
we'll do it at a decent speed
i think we have to to compete in ideas
here one is the global aspect ratio of
the thing and then the other one is the
local aspirations that we see in
collections of children
and i think this this second one looks
better because there are many
local 45 degrees that we see here
and then we we accept a few we are
jungles
i see what you're saying i see what
you're saying you're saying if we look
at the distribution
that it will be peaked around 45 degrees
for the local angle you think it's the
local angle that matters not
i see that's an interesting theory okay
so that looks terrible
okay so let's go
so can we write the code okay so here we
go
oh my gosh
yeah i think that actually that that
that sounds right i mean it seems like
yeah if you have if you have
if you've ever seen one of these graphs
i don't know if you have any that really
do this or they're just
it just has lots of these really wide
ones it's just a bunch of horizontal
lines it's really hard to tell where any
of them are going it's like a maze
well but so okay so so what we need and
maybe somebody could just write this
code is the thing that computes the
angle distribution for one of these
layouts and then what we would do
is
we would try okay so then we could
compute
okay how how easy is it to compute on
the fly
the
given a tree
can you compute for aspect ratio a
what the angle distribution is is that
an easy thing to do
so that we could then max you know we
could then try and
you know tune the aspect ratio to
achieve
a
you have the peak
i think that changing the aspect ratio
will just like kind of linearly change
the all those angles or not quite
linearly but like by the the cosine or
something like that
i see what you're saying so you're
saying that we can shift the peak that
all that's going to happen is we've got
an initial histogram
and by changing the aspect ratio we are
merely making a simple deformation
that's obviously correct right that
we're
we're changing those angles
in a simple trigonometric way and
they're all they're all
you know they're all independently being
changed
so the question is what is the original
aspect ratio distribution
sorry what is the original angle
distribution
and then it's going to be some wiggly
distribution that has some outliers
and then we're going to have to ask how
do we move that angle distribution to be
most you know have the
i don't know whether we want the
greatest mass around 45 degrees or
whether we want quantiles
near 45 degrees or what
see what i'm saying
i mean i really would like to can
somebody see how to do this how do i get
given a particular vertex yeah here's
what i would do so given this graph
let's let's take that graph
here
line 40.
let's say
uh 942 for example
okay so here's what i'm going to do
so for every
over the vertex list
okay let's do um
graph angles
graph g
given the vertex list
for every vertex
[Music]
we say
um
uh
what do you want to do
annotation value
of what
of
list g comma the vertex comma vertex
coordinates
i might be learning better how to use
annotation value okay i think you can
also use graph embedding for that but
yeah yeah that's what i was going to do
i was going to say graph embedding
but it's okay well i don't know if
many's trying to re-compete something
yeah yeah well no we do graph embedding
once
okay so so go ahead what were you saying
in
in the first argument list g comma slot
second argument vertex coordinates
okay but that that's good non-string
vertex coordinates right yeah okay right
but that's that's not getting me quite
what i wanted because whatever then you
vertices or something like that
um
or adjacency list that's what it's
called
might be better
why would we why would adjacency let's
be better because what i was going to do
you can omit one argument but it doesn't
matter you can also use vertex out
component
okay
of g comma hash on the vertex list and
then that's a vertex out component
that's one level that i just want the
one level that that's infinite levels
adjacency list would have done one level
oh i didn't know that
what is it jason silas so jason's a list
for one vertex
no i don't want to do it for the graph i
want to do it for a single vertex
because i've got to go over this look
what i've got to do is i've got to get
the vertex out you can put the vertex in
the second argument then
okay hold on
and we say if
length of that
is less than two
then nothing because we don't have an
angle when
right
otherwise
we want to say those two components we
want to say the we want to get the
annotation value of those two
coordinates
and then what we want to say actually we
don't want to take you want to transpose
it and you want to take the mean of the
the y's and you want to take the min max
yeah
well i was i was i was just going to
take look we've got to get the the
original vertex as well so we've got to
take um in addition to that we've got to
have that and then we've got to say
we've got to have the angle
between oh i see you've got the min max
of those yes i get it so you're saying
of these things here
we've got to say
um and that's going over vertex list
even i put something in a chat
not sure even it
but it's right or not
okay
thank you
oops what happened oh i see
that's the whole thing
yeah
okay
get rid of that yeah i don't want the
module
cool okay let's let's get let's actually
make our histogram happen outside of it
okay so
okay so let's take our original tree
here
um
which was let's do our aspect ratio okay
so as a function of aspect ratio so
we'll take line 26
and let's go ahead the aspect ratio
actually change the embedding or just
the plot
i assume it changes the embedding
doesn't it
that's a good question does anybody know
i
i think it doesn't affect the embedding
well it'd be easy to emulate it though
because you could just multiply that m
variable by
by the aspect ratio or by yeah you know
what i mean
okay let's make a histogram of these
interesting maybe divide by degree
yes
well isn't that interesting okay let's
let's give it a few more bins
it really likes
that angle whatever the heck that angle
is
okay
yeah
but let's try changing the aspect ratio
maybe it's already optimizing for
something similar to what we're talking
about look at this what the heck is
going on this this definitely changed
this changed the distribution
so it does care okay let's do a very
basic thing here if nick thinks his code
is right
um
let's take this thing here
let's take something very basic why
don't you take one that's going to give
you a very extreme ridiculous result if
you want to see if the code is right
okay i was going to say here let's just
make a table of these
with aspect ratio a goes from
let's say 0.1 to 2
in steps of
0.1 for example
well okay so this is indicating that
they're identical
which is wrong
well which is wrong
but but that suggests that something is
happening
um
oh yeah i've forgotten vector angle
which is the obvious thing to use here
um
nick what did you do here so let's just
take a look what you did
uh
so for each
vertex out component right i compute
subsets of each of edges
and make a vectors like a pair of each
pair of vectors i just can put an angle
between them
okay so you're not computing the maximum
splay at a particular node you're
computing so in other words you at this
node is he's computing all the displays
and then just using the max
maybe we should put an ac no i'm not
putting any max there maybe we should
put maximum
for each vertex
so uh so what you're computing is every
one of these contributes to the
histogram yeah everywhere
okay i claim
you know what i think we want to know
the angle relative to the vertical
i think that's what's more relevant i
think it's the angle of every edge
relative to the vertical i claim
rather than the splay angle
my new hypothesis
okay well actually that's those are
probably directly correlated because
it's going to be pretty much symmetrical
right if it's a balanced tree
i guess yeah
um
okay jonathan has to leave in a few
minutes and i do too so let's let's take
a quick look okay so we've defined the
problem here we clearly
can you say if you're okay with the new
like styles
yes the answer is yes i think they look
good but i think you should put a
minimum aspect ratio in if you can
okay and i think this option we just
discussed for the children display is
also good
but i think the styles look good
all right but i think we do need to fix
this aspect ratio thing
and i think the the first step is this
minimum and maybe you could do a little
bit of investigation of this
histograming thing
okay can we look at proof object for a
minute please
um
okay yes so there are two parts here one
is that the change that
nick is proposing
which is this first part and second are
improvements or extensions
and so i think the important part is
this first part
okay and um
but so wait a second just to give me
some sense here
this
exists versus for all
what is this
what's the improvement proposal here
certain improvements it's more
bug fix because previously find the
question proof ignored
basically existential quantifier or
other way around everything was a
existential quantifier
i thought everything was a universal
quantifier
no it was actually existential it's like
if you put a 4 roll it was treating it
as constants and vault meister was
teaching all those variables as
constants
because involved meister it is
specifically
there is a strategy when there is a
grounded
well well there is like not grounded
theorem
it tries to go anyway so what would this
effect would this have if somebody left
out the for all
in the proof that in the theorem they're
trying to make
you're saying i mean like the typical
example i use prove p dot q equals q dot
p given below in algebra
you're saying that right now when i say
prove p dot q equals q dot p that that
is not quantified is that correct
obviously there's no for all it's just a
constant it's the same as specific
exists existential
okay so but the theorem i think i'm
proving isn't the theorem i mean
i'm proving the wrong theorem it's
basically what you're saying in that
case if i think i'm proving the general
p dot q equals q dot p i'm actually not
proving that although it doesn't matter
in this case
yeah right basically that's how it was
before we were proving the only the
special cases
and if you promote by refutation the
proofs in general much shorter
um
okay token event proof graph that seems
like a an obvious win
um i mean that's basically emulating
what was in the meta math post right
yeah i just think it's difficult
so just the quantifier thing how does
that relate to full simplify i mean like
just full simplify
this is also a problem for simplify
a little bit
simplify use this world meister only
when there's assumptions and explicit
axioms yeah it requires
for also that's
in the in the assumptions in the
assumptions yes yeah but the thing that
nick is pointing out is that in the
in the target that you are proving
there's an issue about whether you
include the for all
right
right so for simplify that there is no
such issue for simplified
i don't think there is a why
why why isn't there that issue in other
words in simplify when you prove p dot q
equals q dot p
you are you can perfectly well assume
that those are
general yeah so so they are they are
they are generally quantified so so
if you
then it's for all
okay and and you're not proving anything
when you're doing simplifying you're
just you're you're just using it
you're reducing it to a hopefully
equivalent expression
right yes so it's expressions are
supposed to be equivalent model
for all things
so
okay fine
okay so here
this is nick's new proposed proof
function is that correct
right
and is this totally different from
from a previous year
it's it's totally different citizen from
scratch it supports critical polymers
and it's structured a little bit
differently but the idea
essentially the same
and how is it using
what is what is confirm assert doing
that that's i see so this would actually
this is using the confirm and close
framework to determine if the proof is
true
yeah yeah it also
checks all the intermediate steps
and then at the end it checks the
conclusion separately
i know that it's transformation mark in
the
um um
and what does this look like right now
i mean right now it's a function right
that is
well this is a function as well
um can i currently currently return true
rather than success
maybe
but
it's not gonna work but
no i know yours isn't gonna work this is
the old one okay
okay
now why is yours so much shorter
because it's a poor refutation
it has a
separate action
it tries to prove it's false whereas
what's this
and this is where it was actually
not the proof that it's intended to do
it treated those
variables as constants
even though it works but
okay well so how do i do the proof that
it's intended to do
well i don't think i don't think you can
okay but in terms of this if i did your
proof with constance would it look the
same as this or not
yeah if you if i
put an existential quantifier explicitly
then do the same thing
okay jonathan this this proof this
existing proof function format is is
yours
can you comment on it i mean you're
using map apps and replaces and so on
and is there some
okay first question is there something
that is not doable with jonathan's
existing proof function
stuff i mean i think it had some bugs
but in addition to that is there
anything that's fundamentally not doable
with it
with the proof function
yeah
well yeah i mean as documented i mean it
doesn't support critical pair limits
right it doesn't validate those
okay whereas nick is validating critical
parallels here
right correct
well that that's what nick claims i
don't know that that's been
independently verified
okay
well so
nor am i in a position to do that but
you know i you know i think
uh jonathan would need to actually
review it and opine on that which as far
as i know he hasn't done
not yet um
if the design is okay i'm happy to go
through and review the actual change
okay but but so i'm trying to understand
i mean
this looks rather different from
jonathan's version
so i'm trying to understand you know
what would you do with this code
other than run it and say great it gives
success
well
you still only can use it for that
but the underlying algorithms you can
use it for actual
like my find replace path i rewrote it
to use all the changes i made so that
it's much easier
explain so i mean you're saying
go ahead i mean
the the ch you're you're actually
ingesting a proof function
for the find replacement well it's like
the same
like derivation of steps like each step
when the actual procedure for
verification and assume some information
about each step
and though this information was missing
in the original proof object because it
was it was a pain to extract it
right now you actually can extract all
the information
without reproducing all the possible
replacements
and do something more than just
verifying
for example for example
you're saying from this lump of code
here you're actually going in and taking
this code apart or what no i'm not
taking well this port this code is just
generated once you i'm not using it but
the same
similar like loop
over steps
oh and all the information from the
proof objects is extracted to
make a path for example
so maybe we need a lower level construct
than proof function maybe we need that
step-by-step generator of things i mean
maybe we need that list of step-by-step
functions that composes to make the full
proof function
so we'd have like a proof step object or
something
yeah a proof step function or you know a
proof
proof step functions plural one for each
proof step does that make any sense or
does it need too much what's the value
of giving it a function as opposed to
just just just being able to extract a
big list and map over
yes that's possible what would the llama
do what what what does it eat what does
it um
so you're saying i mean in the way of
understanding these things that we have
here for example
we have here lemma
plus lemma
with a particular rule of inference
gives another lemma
is that what you're pro that that's
something we don't currently have right
is is we have only replace as a way of
doing effectively a particular form of
rule of inference we don't yet have
built-in ways to do sort of
take two lemmas and apply them
you know to each other
is that right but that's what we need
correct in this in this case if we had
to take two lemmas and apply them to
each other
then we would have the steps we the raw
material for the steps we need here is
that correct
oh yeah yeah but but those steps are
pretty true you just do unification
and do the replacement
and that's what multi replace for
example does but for all the cases
here you just specify in the actual
position where this happens
and that's all the difference
right but so what we need is a version
of replace
that does unification
and that lets you give the position and
it does unification is that right yeah
yeah well it you can also specify like a
specific position in the multiple place
so much actually is like
oh yeah we need to reproduce each
individual lemma
okay well maybe that's what we should be
using maybe we should you know make that
a top-level thing
we're not gonna solve this all today and
i'm i'm about to be late again for
something so let's just take a quick
look here at what
i mean is there a
okay so
yeah so there is a main issue here which
is the current structure of proof object
i mean when we do find the questionable
proof of theorem comma actions we get
backs a proof object with a logic which
is currently equational logic then the
theorem and the actions again and then
proof the whole content of the object is
proof
now what nick is suggesting is to change
that to proof objects containing an
association
which contains the various fields
as opposed to
decisional arguments
well right and and they're
it's a minor thing but
yes
and they're sort of i would say sort of
two issues one is
i mean i personally think you know
having something structural is superior
because you know you can test things
more easily without evaluation
you know people can disagree on that
point but the other thing is
in his implementation he's made no
provision for old style
proof of you know proof objects which
means
anybody who has a proof object stored in
their notebooks or whatever that's not
going to work it's not going to work i
mean so okay so what you're saying it i
which i think i agree with is you like
the direction that next thing is going
but there needs to be a bridge to the
past
i'm you know i'm not so hot on the
direction he's going in but i i won't go
so far as to claim it's absolutely wrong
but there absolutely has to be a bridge
to the past
i i want to bring up another point which
is that the synthetic geometry prover is
using
the old proof proof object structure
right
and
yes that's not obviously compatible with
this association format because for
instance in a synthetic geometry proof
there aren't constants and variables
right it's not a very big problem it's
just a
part
versus a key
it's a literally one minute change but
the point is here is that
all the old proof object is already
broken
and you still have to regenerate the
proof if you want to
get the whole proof object to work it's
like
all that works is dependency graph
besides that the proof itself is
unusable
right well then you could have something
that evaluates the old form into the new
form with the new proof
that they already have like if you have
a proof object
old style object if you relate it
you get a new one
it just regenerates all the people from
scratch so what was that so it'll take a
much longer time than you might expect
though because it'll actually do a proof
yeah but that's not the worst thing in
the world i mean so you're saying but
okay what's the story with the synthetic
geometry proverb because that has to be
tracked down i don't think there's
anybody in this meeting no unless ian do
you know about that well i i know about
it um
and you know i
you know they're they're certainly not
ready for 13-1 they might
uh
you know release it as a as a paclet
after
13-1 is out um
okay so they so
and we had we had certain hooks for them
so that they could you know you reuse
proof object with their slightly
different stuff and that's where i think
the advantage of having something you
know positional arguments then you know
it's very easy to sort of
evaluationlessly pattern match
against the structure and say oh i'm
going to go down this code path because
this is a
synthetic geometry proof rather than uh
well okay i would argue differently
which is that if these proofs have very
different kinds of things in them
then it's much better to have an
association
it's a fourth argument that is different
so the structure of of type of logic
theorem axioms is is this time and
though that's the information that's
needed for example for typesetting so
you can use it without evaluation
while the new method will have to go
through evaluation and so it's
potentially a source of evaluation leaks
i don't think you have to you just wrap
it around
with with the appropriate amount of
anomaly
and
it gets more complicated so i mean we
can't keep the the same four arguments
and structure and then you have full
freedom in the fourth to put
associations and everything you want
there
nick what do you think i think it's
pretty typical that that you know you
have at least like one argument at the
beginning that's like
you know
what kind of object is this and then
after that maybe you have an association
and in this case maybe it's in the
fourth position or something
if we think that this will always be
a type of logic
an axioms
a
i'm sorry what's actually next it's
theorems next and then axioms
so right yes same order as in the
constructor find the question of proof
nick what is your objection to having
the first three arguments like that and
then
in the
fourth argument having an association
well my objection was that it's not
always the case i think it's like for
example theorems can be dropped for
example you i can make a proof object
that just generated by completion you
just give it an action that generates a
bunch of theorems without you specifying
an exact goal that you want to reach
right
that's some does find equation or proof
support that
i do i have a function
i have a function that just makes a
completion already
that that construct the same proof
object without a theorem
well you could put all the funerals that
it proved
or found in a list of fields but it's
not the funeral that you specify you
just specify these two axioms like the
things no i guess it's a theory
right i get it but i mean that's a
different thing than find equational
proof which is a
finder proof of this particular theorem
but yeah
find the question proof it's a proof
object we are discussing i i know the
same object
yeah i understand that i understand that
but the question of whether the proof
object says automatic or all in that
position doesn't seem to me
uh
you know that doesn't seem critical to
me
they
okay this we're not going to resolve
this right now we're going to have to
bring this back
sorry we got we got lost in the trees
here for a while
um
and
you know
all right well i think that'll you know
i'll i'll
you know i presume we won't discuss this
for another week or two um and i'll i'll
try to take a look at
because nick has made some updates since
the last time i looked at his pr so
and okay is it possible to just outright
fix the bugs
without introducing this new format
neck
yeah yeah the format is too real to
change it's just okay so fine so let's
look for 13 1 let's try and fix the bugs
and not change the format and then for
13.2 let's revisit
some new functions
multi-replace
uh
and those things and try and actually
sort of get this right but let's for
this version let's just make sure we fix
the bugs
okay
and uh all right i have to go for those
following these live streams i'm
actually about to do another live stream
about history of science and technology
but um uh
good thank you all very much
see you later from here